- And I know that there's
actually the black trans movement,
as well happening right now, like,
Black Trans Lives Matter, right?
- Yeah. Oh yeah it's been
going on for a very long time,
and I think we've just,
people have started to pay attention,
and I mean, we have a
long way to go, right,
like there's unfortunately
in the month of June,
there'd been murders of
several trans people,
all black trans women,
well except for one,
mostly black trans women this month,
but also trans women, trans
people of all races and genders.
Tony McDade is a trans
man, he was murdered,
May 27th, two days after George Floyd,
in Tallahassee, Florida,
by police officers there.
So it's a movement that's
been going on for a long time,
and there's attention now
that we're getting to understand now
when we say Black Lives Matter,
that has to include all black lives,
that like,
just because I'm transgender,
doesn't mean that I'm not
affected by the same racism
that the rest of the
world is also affected by.
So we're getting there,
we have a long way to go,
in terms of really being
fully inclusive of everyone,
but that's the country,
that's the world, so.
- Yeah. But I think, I don't know,
do you feel hope with
what's happening right now,
a little bit?
Sometimes, it depends on the day,
sometimes I feel like overwhelmed,
and I'm like, we are
never gonna get anywhere.
And then other days, I feel like,
you hear these stories of like, just hope,
and people doing the right thing,
and that makes me hopeful.
Where are you at?
- Politicians don't always give me hope,
but the people give me hope.
Seeing, I mean I think after-
- Well there's more
people than politicians.
- Amen, preach.
So after what happened to George Floyd,
I think that if people
hadn't taken to the streets,
and hadn't, you know, mobilized,
then I would really feel
off, I would feel horrible.
And I thought, you know,
after you know, we saw
Mike Brown, and Tamir Rice,
and Trayvon Martin,
that something would change.
So I have hope because
the people have mobilized,
and that the people are not relenting,
and I think we need to not relent,
and we need to continue
to make our demands,
and I feel emboldened and inspired
by everyone out there
marching, so keep marching,
keep protesting peacefully,
and keep spreading love and awareness,
and keep demanding justice.